in this video you're going to learn how
to rewrite literal equations and what
that involves is solving for a specific
variable we're going to go through three
examples together I'll show you how this
works so the first example we've got 2x
- 3 y = 4 Z + 5e and we want to solve
for the variable y we want to get this y
by itself on one side of the equal sign
and that's what it means to solve for it
now the way I like to think about it is
if I'm trying to get this y by itself
I'm here on the left side of the
equation I like to think about working
from the outside in towards that y so I
would say to myself what's furthest away
from this y it would be this 2x term
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to subtract 2x from both sides of
the equation right so if I do that the
two x's are going to cancel we're going
to get -3 y equal 4 Z + 5 e - 2x okay
now working again still from the outside
in towards that y I've got to get rid of
this -3 notice they're right next to
each other side by side that means
they're multiplied we want to do the
opposite which is to
divide both sides by -3 so if we do that
you can see that we've solve for our
particular variable that we were
interested in y = 4 Z + 5 e -
2x divid -3 and you got it now you could
rewrite this in a slightly different
fashion if you wanted you could divide
each of the terms individually by -3 um
that's another way to look at it but
this is a pretty good uh right there so
number two now let's look at this one
this one's a little bit more challenging
it says solve for x and notice that
there's an X in this term here as well
as in this term here that's what makes
this a little bit more challenging so
what you want to do is you want to get
the variable that you're interested in
on one side of the equation everything
else on the other side so let's go ahead
and get everything that has an x on the
left left side of the equation the way I
would do that is I would subtract 2
Ax from both sides so if we do that that
comes out to 5x - 2
ax - 3 y = 4 Z now we want to get this
term that doesn't have an X in it to the
other side by doing the opposite so
we're going to add 3 y to both sides and
that gives us 5x - 2 ax = 4 Z + 3 y I
usually put a little line through my Z
so it doesn't look like a two and now
we're trying to get this x by itself but
because it's in these two terms what I'm
going to do is I'm going to factor the X
out it's kind of like doing the
distributive property backwards or in
Reverse okay so I'm dividing it out you
can check your work if you distribute it
back in you'll get back the 5x minus 2
ax and then now what we want to do is we
want to get this x by itself now notice
it's right next to this 5 - 2 a side by
side side that means that they're
multiplied together what's the opposite
of multiplying dividing so we're going
to divide both sides by 5 - 2
a and these are that term is going to
cancel with that group okay so now we're
just left with X is equal to 4 Z + 3 y
all over 5 - 2
a and you got it one last example number
three uh we've got a form here you
probably recognize it's the surface area
of a cylinder and we're solving for H
meaning we're trying to get this H by
itself on one side of the equal side so
again I like to think about you know
working from the outside in towards the
H if I'm on the right side of the
equation what's furthest away from the h
it would be this 2 pi r 2 term so what
we'll do is we'll subtract 2 pi r 2 from
both
sides of our equation here so if we do
that the 2 p pi r squ are going to
cancel we get s - 2i r^ 2 = 2i
RH okay now still working from the
outside in towards that H you can see
this whole group 2 pi r is right next to
the H right side by side that means that
they're multiplied together the opposite
of multiplying we know is dividing so
we're going to divide both sides by 2 pi
r and that's going to give us our H by
itself now you can flip the equation I
think that's what I'll do here just to
make it look a little nicer just kind of
read a little bit better we're going to
say the height or H is equal to S - 2i
r^ 2 all divided by 2 pi r and you got
it so great job if you're able to follow
these examples if you want more practice
which I recommend follow me over to that
video right there and we'll do some more
practice go ahead and pause the video
see if you can try some of the examples
on your own and of course we'll go
through them together I'll see you in
that video